Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my Game Of Thrones Bonus video I wanted
to talk about the Widlings.
The show hasn’t spent a lot of time with
them this season, as of right now the Thenn’s
are the only new tribe we’ve met.
So I’m going to do a breakdown of their
history and some of the more notable groups
up to this point on the show.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Game of Thrones videos every week.
Next week there’s a break, there won’t
be a new episode.
So I’ll just be doing a bonus video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it and feel free
to leave me suggestions for topics.
Round 7 of the giveaway starts tonight when
I post my review video.
So let’s talk some free folk.
That’s actually what they call themselves.
Like citizens of America call themselves Americans.
The term wildling is like a racial slur that
people in the seven kingdoms use to describe
them.
As in, they are wild.
Ygritte spent most of Season 3 trying to dispell
Jon Snow’s preconceived notions about their
culture.
The funny thing is that people north of the
wall also have a derrogatory term for people
south of the wall.
They call them “kneelers”.
As in they kneel to a king.
Like Aegon the conqueror.
So just because the people south of the wall
are super racist, doesn’t mean that the
Free Folk can’t also be super racist.
There’s just a lot of racism going around
in a song of ice and fire in general.
I like to think Jon was a pretty open-minded
guy, but the other high born people at the
Night’s Watch like Janos Slynt are extra
super racist.
The interesting thing about the Free Folk
is that yes, culturally they are a group of
people that adhere to a similar belief system.
But in reality, they’re made of hundreds
of small tribes and clans.
Some larger than others.
They’re like a patchwork society of people,
all with their own communities.
Because life is so hard beyond the wall, those
communities tend to be pretty insular.
Which is why it was such a huge deal when
Mance Rayder united them.
And not just them, he also got the Giants
to come and play.
He is pretty charismatic, but really I think
he just showed them all a picture of a white
walker and everyone collectively crapped their
pants and started running for the Wall.
Where did there society originate from though?
The oldest known inhabitants of westeros are
the The Children of The Forest, but they’re
a whole different race, the oldest human inhabitants
we know about are the First Men about twelve
thousand years ago.
It’s totally possible there were other humans
in Westeros before that, but record keeping
didn’t really become a thing till the Andals
came and formed the seven kingdoms, which
was thousands of years after that.
The Thenns, those cannibals we just me in
episode 1, consider their people to be the
last of the first men.
Technically, everyone living in the seven
kingdoms is a descendant of the Andals, not
the first men.
But there’s a lot of interbreeding we can
talk about in a second.
And quick side note.
The Thenns, are actually not part of the Free
Folk.
They’re actually a whole nation of their
own.
The Free Folk are more like a free range group
of people like Craster, just living without
a real government or a single leader.
The Thenns are a fully formed nation state.
A pretty big one when you look at the map
here.
The Free Folk kind of became an amalgam of
people who descended from the first men and
just migrated north during the Andal invasion
and people who were born in the south and
just didn’t want to live under the rule
of the King anymore.
So when we first met Mance Rayder’s army
in Season 3, we were seeing core Free Folk.
Like the free range communities, the Giants,
which are their own separate race, clearly.
The Thenns, who we now know are also a separate
nation with laws and a leader called the Magnar.
The show is playing with a lot of the distinctions
between the different groups beyond the wall.
But generally all you need to know is that
Thenns are different from Free Folk are different
from Giants.
The show made the Thenns cannibals too, and
that’s a small change from the books.
The real cannibals were another community
beyond the wall called the Skagos the show
decided not to feature.
Right now Mance is the King Beyond the Wall
because he united all of the biggest societies
beyond the wall.
He tries to downplay the term King, just because
not bowing to a king is one of their core
beliefs.
But he’s not the first person to do it.
There have actually been six people since
the wall was built to do it.
A single person, or in one case two brothers,
united everyone in the north to try and get
past the wall so they could invade the south.
Which is funny, because it completely ignores
the real reason the Wall was built.
To seal off the lands of always winter.
Which you can see on the map here.
Not keep out the free folk living all over
the rest of the north here.
Those other people living here at the time
even fought with the Children of the Forest
and the other First Men to end the last great
battle with the White Walkers.
Then the wall was built and over the centuries
the people in the south started to forget
that the people in the north were their friends.
And that’s when the term Wildling became
a racial slur and relations devolved to the
point at which we’re seeing on the show
now.
Everyone has forgotten about the true threat.
Everyone except Mance Rayder and a few other
people on the show.
The most densely populated areas are naturally
in Thenn and the Haunted Forest.
The further North you go the colder it gets
and even Free Folk have their limits.
Crasters for example is the closest village
to the wall.
If you can call it a village.
And as of the events of Episode 6 this season.
It no longer exists.
Back in season 3 when Jon first met Mance
and saw his army they were up here in the
Frostfangs.
The raiding party we last saw in episode 3,
with Ygritte, Tormund Giant’s Bane and the
Thenns was just directly south of Castle Black.
So the raiders are attacking from the other
side of the wall.
Which is a huge problem because there aren’t
really a lot of defensive positions on the
south side of
the wall.
After the Night’s King, remember this guy.
Turned into a white walker and started enslaving
the other Night’s Watch brothers.
He rebelled against the seven kingdoms and
turned the Night’s Watch into it’s own
small kingdom for a little while.
As a result, when he was defeated, laws were
passed that said the Night’s Watch could
never build defenses on the south side of
the wall.
So that if the Night’s Watch ever went bonkers
again in the future, they wouldn’t be able
to sustain a fortified battle against the
seven kingdoms.
As an unfortunate consequence of that, if
the Free Folk attack them from the south.
They’ll have a much easier time of taking
Castle Black.
This is what we’re getting ready to watch
play out in the next episode.
So cross your fingers that the rest of the
brothers listen to Jon Snow’s council.
Because everyone but Sam and some of the new
recruits seem pretty ignorant.
So what I’m really excited to see tonight
is what Jon Snow and the other brothers do
to repel the raiders.
And remember, this isn’t Mance Rayder’s
army, they’re a much much larger force that’s
still on the other side of the wall.
The raiders are trying to open the gates by
the time Mance’s army arrives at the wall.
So you have a small force here poking the
Night’s Watch at their weak point and this
massive army on the other side getting ready
to flow through this little area.
And they’re converging it at about the same
time.
So this is all happening at once.
Be sure to send a raven to your loved ones.
Because it’s going to be very very bloody.
I’m really curious if they’ll do any more
cannibal jokes.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what you’re hoping to see in
tonight’s episode.
I think we’re all crossing our fingers for
a “You know nothing Jon Snow” line.
Ygritte is pretty pissed right now.
So we’ll see.
So tonight I’ll post my review after the
episode airs.
And then tomorrow I’ll post my Q&A, be sure
to subscribe to get everything.
And keep leaving me your suggestions for bonus
videos.
You guys have been giving me a lot of fun
ideas lately.
Right now click here for my episode 7 video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here for my Q&A.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!